[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round seven of the
summer classic here in st. Louis it was
peace on earth for group a where every
game was drawn only half points stagger
of a sheaf Dhirubhai Lee varoujan
Akopian and Samsa beyond in the
standings two victories in Group B
including JJ a lemur on D keeping his
first place hopes alive meanwhile after
a draw was stuck open
kamil dragon could clinch his field with
one round despair coverage of round 8
the penultimate round starts now 20
international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
calm presents the first ever summer
chess classic
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the singles
Chess Club studio in the 2018 summer
chess classic I am women with Master
Katrina Nemcova and I'm joined by
international master Eric Rosen today we
have round eight of the tournament which
leaves us only with last round tomorrow
let's see let's review the results from
the last last round to see who is
closest to to win the tournament yeah we
have a very peaceful day yesterday in
Group A all draws so not too much
changing in the standings but we can see
that if we take a look at the standings
we can see the sea star Bayley still
leaving group a with a very impressive
five and a half out of seven points for
erosion of Cobian right behind the Seif
in clear second place with five points
and Sam Sam seven right behind bar in
third place with four and a half out of
seven points in the results for a
groupie
we had Robert a kesariya an having a
draw against Daenerys adora cassava
bloody rubella scoring his first point
again Josh fried l JT Ali Miranda
keeping his eyes on the first place by
beating today Abraham Ian and Andrus
took open drawing against caramel dragon
Alejandra Ramirez again having a draw
against Sergei Matenga
this brings us to standings and we see
camel dragon is still the sole leader of
the group B with five points out of
seven and we have a four-way tie for the
second place where JJ Ali Miranda and
raised to copying Robert Alcazar Ian and
Sergey Michiko all have four points and
we should note that Camille dragon if
everything goes his way he could clinch
victory today
if he wins and the players behind him
stumble but I think that's pretty
unlikely given there's so many players
tied for second place so Group E is
likely going to come down to tomorrow's
final round and to review the torment
tournament format we have to then play
around draw beans with the time control
of 90 minutes for 40 moves plus 30
minutes for the remainder of the game
with the 30 30 second increments
for a move one and we should keep in
mind there is a 30 move no draw rule
meaning players cannot agree to a draw
before move 30 however there is an
exception if the game ends in threefold
repetition players can accept or how to
draw up a form of 30 and we've seen that
a few times throughout this tournament
and as we said before tomorrow is the
last round so join us early the game is
starting at 11:00 a.m. Central time
because if there is a tie if there is a
playoff it will be we are making a space
which we will start at 5:00 p.m. that's
right so please set your alarm clocks
earlier two hours earlier for that
matter and we'll begin the broadcast
tomorrow at 1:30 p.m. at st. Louis time
and a pairings for group a yeah we have
some exciting matchups underway
Benjamin Bach against Peter prohaszka
euros Arabic against tournament leader
of a thief dar Bailey Sam Savion against
firuzan a Cobian Daniel Friedman drawing
Renacci mabye of in a very quick game
and Alexander in judge against Geoffrey
Jean and a key matchup for today is Sam
Savion against vara Kobe on two very
strong American grandmasters Vera Coburn
has not lost a game yet but his position
did not look very pleasant so let's
glance at the game that's right we have
clear second-place vs. clear first
player clear third place and both
players I'm sure really wanting to win
today to catch up to receive Tara Bailey
but if we take a look at the position I
mean the the structure is relatively
symmetrical lots of tension along the
e-file both sizes both sides have
doubled up their rooks and I'm not sure
if either side has much to play for in
this position
maybe we can argue Sam's position is a
bit more pleasant more active Queen on
d5 pressuring both the d5 and b7 pawns
but anything to play for for whites
white would really like to have dark
square bishop and control some dark
square saddam dark squares but because
there are no bishop i think it's very
hard to proceed and maybe go for an
advantage that's right and both players
managing their time pretty well still
far away from time troubles so this
could be a longer fight but if I had to
put money on this game I would I would
predict a relatively peaceful draw
so let's glance at the pairings for a
group being we have some exciting
matches ahead of us
Daenerys adraka so are playing against
Andre matsuhiko camel dragon the leader
playing against Alejandro Ramirez Tata
Abraham Ian against Andres to cope in we
already have a result from the game Josh
Fidel against AJ Ally Miranda it was a
rather uninvolved uneventful game they
agreed on a draw and the last board is
Robert a Caesarea and against value Mira
Bella's right and the key matchup of
today is kamil dragon against Alejandro
Ramirez tournament leader I'm sure
looking for blood in this game Camille
has the white pieces and if we take a
look at the position I would have to be
happy with the white side we can see
both players they're pondering the
position it is Alejandro's move he
doesn't seem too pleased I do want to go
back and show a very instructive moment
from this game going back to move 21
after 96 white played the rather
ambitious and very explosive pawn f5
trying to rip apart the center with
blacks King still on eh and if we go
forward to see how the game continued
after King side Castle F take e6f Nikki
Sixx Queenie four it looks like black is
going to be left with this kind of
long-term weakness on e6 and we discuss
this position before the broadcast and
we also mentioned how white is just
perfect with his pieces the rooks are
dominating the D file there are no
weaknesses in White's camp and the night
on b6 is it's very restricted it doesn't
have really a good spot to go to it's
right
a few murmurs have been played after
rook f e8 Queen d4 Rock BC its Queen d6
Queen b7 and Queen e5 brings us to the
current position I might have to argue
that White has some weakness especially
with these pieces lined up on the C file
and having committed to b3 this Knight
is a bit less defended but I mean
White's positions he was very stable and
it seems like white is trying to play a
positional game we saw a Camille going
for this Queen trade if Queens did come
off the board it would be just a much
more pleasant positional endgame for
whites
so perhaps Alejandro is trying to keep
Queens on the board to try and create
some attacking chances later on
but Camila is the leader of Group B it
looks like he's happy with this position
so let's review the prices for the
tournament to see what players are
fighting for yeah we have a very
generous prize fund for group a twenty
two twenty two thousand dollars on the
line six thousand dollars for first
place and it's going to come down to the
final rounds to see who can take home
big bucks and a prize fund for a group B
we have a total of forty thousand
dollars and the first prize the winner
takes on four thousand dollars so far it
looks like Camille is the closest one to
go but we have to keep in mind that
soggy Marchenko is still playing him
tomorrow so anything can happen that's
right I think if Sergei can win his last
two rounds will at least have a share at
first place so sometimes towards the end
of the tournament you don't want to get
or you don't have the the money being
the only thing on your mind I've been in
the situation many times before and when
you start thinking about money and what
how much you could how much you can
actually win if if you take first place
then it can have a negative impact on
your your your chess playing so let's go
to see some games I thought there's a
very interesting position between
Alexandra engaging Jeffrey Zhang yeah
let me find that game a very imbalance
position we can take a look at the
current situation after rookie seven it
looks like White has everything to play
for actually want to go back and show
someone interesting and weird moment in
this game around and move sixteen there
was a bit of Dancing with both sides it
looked like there was almost a
repetition about to be played after
queena 490 h5 queen III the night
returned to f6 the Queen returned to F
for the night return to h5 but Alexander
in Jets turned down the repetition with
with a fresh move here Queen g5 and
after Knight to f6 in judge did not
retreat the Queen and just take the draw
he went for the the very ambitious pawn
d5 going for the central expansion and
if we see how the game unfolded after
kontiki 5 a la Alexander in judge
continued his aggression with Pawnee 5
maybe somewhat of applause
rifice lunging forward with the pawn
making the light retreat also leaving
box Bishop pretty depressed on on b7 I
think this is a very nice idea to really
look at d5 pawn takes d5 and E 5 the
pawn on d5 it's extra black is pawn up
but we have to keep in mind how good
this pawn or how bad this pawn is my
coach used to say you know this is a
double agent it is up it is like it
looks like it's black but maybe it's
playing for for the white camp because
it's blocking the bishop on b7 it does
not allow black pieces to have
cooperation and suddenly maybe we can
see moves like Ruby for Ruby 4 and
creating some pressure on the King side
I very much agree this pawn on d5 not
only as a blocking blacks blacks bishop
on b7 but it's just a long-term weakness
white can win it back at any points I
like the the move engine shows in this
position Queen h5 avoiding any Queen
trade following the very general
principle in chess when you're the one
attacking you want to keep Queens on the
board to maximize your attacking chances
and already we can see some targets for
white in the position this planet of
seven and this pawn in h7 very easy for
white to attack not only with the Queen
and the bishop targeting f7 but also the
potential of Knight g5 in the position
seems like a fun and lively position for
engines and sometimes we can also glance
on the clock to see what's happening we
see Geoffrey Zhong having only 17
minutes whereas external Indyk still has
almost 30 minutes to to go before the
round before the move 40 so black will
have to also figure out how to find the
best news while having only 17 minutes
to go yeah let's get to the current
position a few more moves have been
played after rook c7 Bishop a4 may be
trying to restrict the knight create
someone annoying pin so Geoffrey
responded with rookie 7 getting out of
the pin brings us to the current
position we can see it's Alexander in
judges move and he looks like a monster
hovering over the board there I do want
to point out a fun fact I believe he's a
tallest Grandmaster in the world
so maybe the somewhat intimidating
opponent to sit across from
so when we see this position I think
there are some interesting of options
that white can do so let's say 95 is one
option there's an interesting line if
white goes ninety-five and black
responds with 86 we can maybe do even 9
takes f7 with the idea of playing ecigs
that's a nice line not really a
sacrifice given that white is
immediately winning back material and in
fact wanted to save the rook with a move
like rookie 7 well I could happily
capture on d7 and as pawn in d7 just a
huge nuisance in blacks position given
that it is defended by the bishop and
perhaps white could go for some
potential pawn promotion tactics with
the very scary Queenie Yeates
unfortunately Oh 95 just happened but
most likely black is not gonna respond
with 86 but there is just a safe move
Knight f8 where black is defending the
87 Square and also controlling the e6
yeah I think knowing that fate will be
most likely in this position not giving
white any tackle opportunities very safe
and solid move not to mention it
unleashes a queen - maybe support the d5
pawn a bit more and now it becomes a
question how does white continue from
here is there a breakthrough move just
white want to maybe look for some slow
expansion move and we see that night if
it happened in the game Jeffrey
responded pretty quickly with this
rather obvious move where we are
defending the pawn on h7 defending e6
and now it's white who has to decide how
to advance other pieces maybe how to
bring more pieces to the attack yeah
whenever you're attacking I like to
compare it to a party where you want to
just invite everyone to the party and
make sure everyone has a good time I was
expecting and judge to maybe try and
improve one of the rooks maybe consider
some type of rook lift or even maybe
play a move like rook t2 to prepare
Bishop c2 but he shows a different idea
a very interesting move maybe someone
unexpected Knight to e4 perhaps going
for the improvement of the night you
know it's about this I mean it's
interesting to see that the knight on d5
is very active but after Knight f8 it's
it's running out of any
any strong threats because 87 is
defended it six is defended so maybe
it's time to put the night somewhere
else and 94 has some threat with threats
with maybe Knight f6 and attacking the
King but also really going to d6 square
where it can create more pressure on in
Black's Camp know I love this idea
getting the Knight to d6 because it's
such a weak square in box position and
if the night lands on d6 it's such a
hard piece to remove given it is
supported by the pawn and black only has
the light squared bishop so the bishop
has no way of actually fighting for the
d6 where this is such a difficult
position for black I think black would
be much happier if the pawn was not on
d5 if the pieces were somewhat different
so I think Alex our initiative a very
nice idea of sacrificing upon having
some advantage and now really making
sure that his pieces have the best
cooperation they can possibly have so
they can attack yeah I really have to
admire in judge his place so far making
use of his attacking resources and now
Geoffrey is under pressure they have
about 14 moves to make until time
control and Geoffrey is just over 15
minutes so that's not a lot of time to
to think especially when there's
critical moments and yes difficult
decisions to make when it comes to
defending White's attack so let's move
on maybe to determine B and game
Daenerys adraka solace our game at
Sankyo the first first board in Group B
right I was taking a look at this game
earlier and it seemed like dinara got a
position which really suited her style
very nice and stable pawn on e5 seizing
a lot of space in the position rooks
very well placed on the center files but
we can see things are heating up after
the move pawn off for attacking the
Queen looks like dinara has to move the
Queen to somewhere somewhere safe by I
do admire White's position just seems
like White has more space especially
with this this target on d7 it's just a
backwards pawn already being attacked by
both the rook on d1 and the knight on d6
I think we can maybe expect to move like
like Queen b3 here I agree I mean when
we look at this position we see that why
did not do anything wrong the rooks are
open on
open files the bishop is developed
knight is developed the pawn on e5 I
think we have to stress how important
respond is because it's blocking to to
black pawns which cannot fight for the
center and suddenly we see black pieces
that are not coordinated the knight on
g7 the knight on b8 I think white must
be pleased with this position and also
if we look at the time we see dinara
having 27 minutes and Sergey mischenko
having only 14 minutes for last 16 moves
that's right when I teach some newer and
maybe lesser experienced players I like
to talk about peace harmony finding
ideal squares for your pieces so they
can work together to pressure pressure
your opponent in this case I think white
has just amazing peace harmony lots of
pieces supporting each other while black
just has pieces scattered all over the
place not really having a cohesive plan
so we do have one more move plate Queen
b3 was not played instead dinara opted
for for the very logical Queen d3
hitting the rook on c4 and also adding
some pressure along the D file so
southern to rook is attack and it cannot
even be defended something like rook a a
c7 because we have to keep in mind that
the night on b6 is also attacking the
rook so there must be a retreat with the
rook but better go I mean the only
actually we do have a move played a ruck
to c5 I was actually expecting perhaps a
more passive rook to c7 but rook c5 a
slightly more active square and we
should keep in mind that the pawn in d7
is defended three times by the rook on
a7 the knight and the Queen so why can't
immediately take it but I would still be
very happy with white in this position
just given the setup of the pieces so do
you think it is time to maybe move the
white pawns on the Queen side because
all our pieces seems to have very good
position very good spaces so maybe
before and go after the rook I do like
this movie for if you can expand with
tempo why not we should keep in mind
that White's knight on d6 is currently
hanging so so it might be favorable for
white to play a counter attacking move
rather than retreating Knights
given that the knight is adding a lot of
pressure to
position so let's let's just play it out
so let's say I play before lycanthrope
doesn't have too many safety spots
I would think either rook could be five
or to c7 don't seem too appealing I feel
like if you go rook c7 my Michael would
be really go to a 4 B 5 to completely
restrict the sorry a 4 B 5 to completely
restrict the knight on b8 because if we
control C 6 and a 6 squares then the
knight is just totally out of the game
oh that's that's a very interesting
positional idea and yeah the problem
with rook c7 is it cuts off the attack
from the Queen on d8 so maybe we'll see
a move like rook b5 but I do want to
note that white has a very nice
positional maneuver similar to the game
that we just saw with Alexander and rich
against Geoffrey Zhang they're very
simple Knight c4 followed by 96 and the
knight is just on a beautiful outpost
square deep in blacks blacks territory
so this might be a theme so far this
round just having a very powerful knight
outpost v6 d6 a very important square so
let's move on to a different game here
we see that white has some advantage
maybe we can go back to group a and take
a look at the tournament leader the
sifter Bailey having the black pieces
against yarrow jariabek and it was a
very interesting position earlier it
looks like some dust has settled and
both sides have a lot of pieces on the
kingside Queen f5 just played offering a
queen trade but things might liquidate
into some kind of Josh ending any
thoughts about this position we also
have to keep in mind that the opponent
b7 can one day just go and run for a
queen so I always like when the pawn can
go the bishops are supporting it so I
wonder if if if white wants to exchange
Queens or not
right I would have to argue that I mean
White's King feels a bit safer given the
bishop on g2 just given like this
classic fee and kind of setup so I guess
it's a question can white find some
useful square for the Queen on f4 maybe
a move like Queen to b8 going for some
some attack along the back rank given
that this Bishop on f8 would be pinned
and also like we can go after the knight
on g4 if we play h3 for the night to go
away then we suddenly have a 5 square
then suddenly maybe Bishop 8 6 threats
that's true h3 would probably be the
threat in the position just trying to
remove the knight on g4 from defending
the black camp interesting position I'm
sure of a thief is
I'm sure yarrow is considering this
interesting queen be a move we should
also note that white would be attacking
the pawn on b7 so maybe a couple of
different threats for the white side the
other idea is that if we take and
exchange the Queen's immediately say
Queens they got five Bishop takes at
five h3 now again forcing tonight to go
away so it has some initiative here we
can't have ninety five coming right now
with with the threat of taking the pawn
and b7 and if you are black and you
decide to to take the pawn on d4 I mean
my bishop is immediately going to c3 and
I don't know if maybe I can have some
some counter play on the diagonal it's
an interesting line maybe some kind of
temporary pawn sacrifice given that
white is just keeping the initiative and
I think this is what we're seeing in
many of these finds where white is
making continual threats trying to
improve the pieces while force box
pieces back but it's still a question is
white getting anything in these site and
these sorts of lines where things are
just getting traded and I mean if the b7
pawn comes off the board and White's not
winning anything more it could just be a
very draw position I agree with every
trade I mean it looks like we are
getting into more equal and draw
position
so maybe we can move on to another game
very interesting positional battle which
catches my eye is a fight between Peter
Prohaska and Benjamin Bach Benjamin with
the white pieces and this just looks
like positional heaven for white I mean
look at this amazing post on c5 for the
rook black's pawn structure is far less
and an optimal given given there's a
backward pawn double pawns
isolated pawn on e5 seems like White has
everything going for him in this game we
had I think I believe - rook and game
yesterday they both finished in a draw
so every time there's a rook and game
there is a big chance that it can end up
in a decisive result but we do keep in
mind we do have to keep in mind that if
you have active rook if you control
maybe the C file here you are having
some advantage and you are the one who
is pushing for for maybe win right there
is an infinite saying that all rook
endings are drawn but I'm sure many
strong players would disagree with that
including Magnus Carlsen and this just
seems like a very easy position to play
for whites and put the put the the rooks
on the C file
maybe transfer the Queen to a4 and I
mean there there's just a couple
long-term targets and it's gonna be very
difficult for Locke to defend all upon
weaknesses in position so I see some
changes in the game I Sandra engage in
Jeffries Young there are no longer
bishops on on the board so can we just
see what happened there yeah let's see
what happened because white did achieve
the knight on d6 but going back to the
position after 94 Bishop c6 played and
this is a surprising decision from
Alexander I would expect him to try and
keep his Bishop on the board with a move
like Bishop b3 or even Bishop c2 but he
decided to trade off and then land the
knight on g6 are on d6 and then after 96
it's White's move white is still for a
choice but not sure I feel like
Alexander maybe had more in the position
yes it looks like Alexander Lee just
simplified a position he's gonna
recapture back the pawn on d5 at one
moment and maybe
he wants to play for some advantage
because he dominates a defile but I also
feel that trading this material it just
doesn't give me doesn't help me with
attacking the black ink so can we expect
some moves as very direct rook take d5
assuming there's no tactics I mean
sometimes you have to be very cautious
as white given that there's a lot of
targets attacks in the center but look I
was actually looking now if we take on
d5 blackened by night at four we have
five coming Wow such a crazy line
everything being attacked in the
position these are positions which just
make my head hurt
well maybe I can just recaptured a rook
on d5 yeah I take t5 I don't think it
looks very interesting but unfortunately
like has a way to to get away so maybe
white cannot capture the pawn right now
on d5 so maybe white we'll start with 95
95 and other resource in the position
but does this allow just rook take me 5
so my idea was that I take the rook you
take and maybe 9 things g7 mmm I mean I
do break through there to to weaken the
King because I do believe that at one
moment I will recapture the pawn on d5
that should not be a problem so if your
King remains weak maybe I can I can try
to take advantage of it certainly an
interesting idea of after a night at 5
perhaps black would not be inclined to
capture on e5 maybe he would have to go
for a move like rookie aides and I'm
sorry to say this but we could see a
potential repetition if White's moved
back to d6
that would not be the most exciting
finale to this game another idea that
catches my eye if we go to the current
position instead of nine f5 perhaps a
very simple g3 just stabilize upon that
h4 prevent Knight f4 and even maybe
prepare this pawn advance pawn f4 planet
5 where the knight would be very
restricted in the position and
and sometimes when you have to active
play you do want to slow down play a
quiet move like g3 to restrict the
opponent and that will allow you to
advance even further later on I mean if
you happen to have G 3 F 4 e 5 you have
just a perfect pawn chain and you can
just slowly push on the kingside so I
really like your g3 move I'm just
worried if I have time for it so what if
I respond
what if black responds with f6 here
trying to undermine the center as
quickly as possible to get the night
away from the d6 square yeah f6 going
against advice a grandmaster Ben
Feingold who says never play f6 but in
this case f6 is a very logical move I
mean why not try and destabilize White's
whole setup in the center and I mean I
would love to take the pawn enough 6 but
I don't think this works tactically due
to the simple work taking one check and
then this night would be hanging so I
would love to make this g3 idea work
somehow
maybe f4 here I mean if you go g3
probably you have to follow up with a
four idea but then another I mean you're
making and another weakness on g3 so
let's say I take on e5 pawn take e5
white has kind of extended but all the
pawns on the Kings side given when this
King on g1 maybe not the safest piece
but it is with purpose it is to try and
reinforce the center and it just seems
like there is there's a lot of tactical
considerations for both sides here and
time is ticking down
can I just capture the new pawn on e5
now with the night mmm I take e5 just
going for going for simplification and
if maybe rook takes five maybe there'll
be too many traits and we will end up in
some choice kind of drawing let's see so
I take I take the knight
rook take E 5 Queen take five well maybe
back is coming out up a pawn in this
position being able to recapture the
knight and defend the d5 pawn but
yeah this actually doesn't seem too
impressive for a white I could play this
mover T 4 and probably hold on for a
draw but I'm sure Alexander Alexander
would want a lot more than this I mean I
guess two pawns here Oh two pawns yeah I
can't count accurately yeah this would
be a great winning chances for black so
we all think I mean we both saw that
this is a great position for white but
maybe white has so many problems with
the pawn hanging only five and that's a
risk that white has taken sacrificing
the pawn and then getting this this
visually appealing structure with the
pawn on e5 and 996 but we can see just
based on a few lines that the structure
could fall apart so it is a risky
position for whites Alexander is still
thinking I think we'll have to certainly
come back to this game very soon so we
look at bag but before that maybe
tournament B I thought there was an
interesting game between Robert August
Arjan and volume arabela's now let's get
to that game another strong night in the
center Wow there's another potential for
this move 96 this is a third game that
we're seeing the possible idea but
blacks Knights are relatively impressive
too
I'm curious how the players got to the
structure cuz earlier I just saw like a
relatively quiet middle game somewhat
murasky mind structure where white had a
good kind of space advantage central
control in the center going forward here
let's see how the position opened up
both sides maybe dancing around with the
Knights Queen f6 played ninety two rook
g8 and then Robert is the first to
strike with this move f4 kicking away
the night from e5 and after Knight g4
rook f3 seems a bit awkward for Locke
given this night on g4 perhaps a bit
misplaced also looming ideas of h3 but
okay I guess Vladimir wasn't wasn't too
uncomfortable just played the simple
move Queen e7 giving the night by
retreating for on FX
after Knight g3 I think this
maybe the the turning point in the
nature of the game very explosive move
pawn b5 kind of coming out of nowhere
given that White has three attackers on
b5 and black only has one defender yes
and black in me so keep in mind that
white wants to expand the position so
let's think like it's not going to play
b5 you take move back and play something
normal let's say Knight f6 just to get
the knight back white we proceed with
before and really kicking the night away
and having an amazing position I mean
the pawns are perfect the knight has to
go back and I think it's very pleasant
for white I mean yeah this is usually
what light aims for in these sorts of
structure is just a very stable well
defended position with the tempt to just
dominate all areas of the board you can
see that in this variation that's
probably why Latimer opted for the very
very interesting b5 pawn advance and
after a take b-58 AP 598 b5 white does
go up a pawn but Vladimir strikes again
with the very explosive on d5 and the
position is just opening up drastically
and seems like white is a 1 under
pressure I mean black is achieving what
he wanted to he has active nice so he's
opening up the position the Queen is
rather indenture on d1 because we have
the rook staring at it kind of on d8 the
King is wheeled diagonal and g1 a7 there
may be something happening for black so
I really like how black is trying to cry
to center and make sure to coordinate
his pieces it's right going forward in
what happened in the game after cat5e
take d5 white did not take the the pawn
on d5 probably with good reason I think
if White's goes up to pawns here there
would be some major concerns with
especially with this King on g1 maybe a
move like 94 and then we can see some
some ideas like Queen c5 maybe some
potential smother mating ideas yes I
mean taking these pawns at least white
decided to play effect to kind of block
the position a little bit and make sure
his King is
it's a little safer I do like you 5
keeping files closed and maybe allowing
White's King to be a bit safer but after
94 the same idea still exists in the
position Queen c5 is a very clear threat
and white has to figure out what to do
here and we have a move white fight h3
trying to push the night away I need you
three played and black immediately
responded with Queen before having no
fear in the position I wonder if maybe
viadimir was expecting h3 and calculated
this out but it seems to be getting very
crazy I must say I really like move
Queen before because now you're you
really cannot move back the night from
b5 let's say 2 to d4 because there is a
threat 93 93 with a simple fork and
black could go up material in this line
so what to do for white this Knight is
tied down to defending the c3 square
does white have to go for the Train and
take on g4 so if white takes the knight
black takes the knight so a very
expected line and I mean white is up a
pawn here but the position still wide
open black still having threats of Queen
c5 or Queen b6 and also not to mention
this looming idea of Knight c3 so why it
would still be under some pressure here
so we have a position where again why
this pawn up
I should be happy with having this extra
material but what is also facing some
difficulties having weaker King having
maybe less coordinated pieces this is
something what that you want to do if
you are black you want to try to
complicate the position and an attack
the King and especially given the time
situation I mean Vladimir has just under
25 minutes Robert below 2 minutes and I
do like the way Vladimir is playing
given his situation the tournament he's
not fighting for one of the top right
one of the top places so he he can take
a lot of risks in this game seems like
that's what he's doing
Robert responded with H take g4 and
seems like we'll see this line play out
I think we
can expect Queen take d5 and there's
still 11 more moves to make until new
40s so Robert is going to be under a
major pressure for several more months
to come
so what do we move on to the game today
Abraham iam against Andres - copying and
really still he was tied for the second
place so he's still a contender trying
to win the tournament so what is
happening on the board right and Andre
is playing the lowest seat in Group B so
I'm sure he's looking for blood in this
game and he's playing very ambitiously
he played a somewhat imbalanced Sicilian
opening VI do you want to focus on the
current position Black is lunging the
king forward and what appears to be a
very interesting and unbalanced endgame
I should note usually in the endgame you
want to use your King as an active piece
given that there's not as many
checkmating ideas in this case Andre is
using that idea to its full extent and
denied on a 5 it's it's kind of it seems
it's out of the really out of the main
situation of what's happening in the
board so black has an easy planning just
wants to take the pawn on h2 and just
push the pawns and white maybe a little
too slow we're doing the same on the
Queen side yeah this position it's all
about it's all about time and it's gonna
come down to a pawn race given that
Black has a keen side Maggiore white has
a queen side majority but blacks
planning just seems to be much faster
and I'm not too impressed with White's
last move Knight to b7 what is this
Knight doing and what is what is white
gonna do about the pawn on h2 I actually
saw that it's a good move before you
said you are not impressed because the
night is finally moving to the center of
the board I mean I said the knight is
kind of off you know over the center it
doesn't do anything now I'm bringing the
Knight to d6
to attack some of the black pawns but
also I'm making a space for a pawn to
maybe run for a queen as well that's
actually a good point so maybe 97 is a
multi-purpose move and I am realizing in
this position there is a tactical idea
for White's
where I don't think black can grab the
h2 pawn right away the
because of the the director Brooke take
f3 and white would actually be going out
material in this position after king
take f3 Brooke take H - so maybe black
has to figure out some other way to make
progress and also figure out how to
capture the h2 pawn safely
so maybe but I can do something like g4
just to push the pond and figure out a
little later how to recapture a barn on
h2 maybe we can play this out positions
with pawn races are always fun to play
out and not always easy to calculate but
a move like g4 what if white just starts
pushing a for what's what's the next
idea for luck the tactical idea with
rook take a 3 so exists and meanwhile
White's just wants to run down the board
so what do we think so I would like to
get get rid of the rook on g2 which is
very difficult so what else can I do so
let's say I played before before hitting
the rook with tempo maybe slowing right
down oh you'll have to probably have to
move to d3 right but then you're maybe
getting into a 4 with 91 ah 91 very true
forking the the two rooks so maybe the
white rook doesn't have a safe place to
go in this position you are actually
still kind of safe after the fork 91
because so let's say Rudy 391 you have
Rudy one move but I still feel if
trading the rooks maybe for advantage
for black right if Knight takes you to
row take f1 the King can come closer
into the position each coupon is hanging
but I don't know this still seems a bit
unclear given White's a pawn nothing
much in its way and white also could win
f7 planning in many lines so you want to
play this or row c7 instant
a good question I'm not entirely sure I
mean it seems like white has a few
different options but rook d3 going into
that line doesn't seem too bad for
whites given this resource with rook do
you want so let's say what if I don't
play g4 I can start with before
immediately mmm you just want to play d4
chase away the rook I do like before
because in this case you're maybe
discouraging the a pawn to advance given
the possibilities of on passant and we
could take a look at the similar line if
rook to d3 91 to d1 maybe it's still
okay for whites given that if white does
go into this line f7 is still hanging in
the end we have to keep in mind that
Tata has only three minutes to to figure
out this position that's always
difficult to calculate to make sure you
know it's safe for me while I'm having
only three minutes to do so that's a
good point and I hate being in in
complicated situations having low time
because then you can't rely on
calculation you have to rely purely on
intuition and while intuition can do you
well in many cases some cases just
require you to to calculate many moves
ahead and this is usually the situation
when you can regret spending so much
time maybe in some previous decisions
that were not as important
I remember reading an article with with
a British Grandmaster was his name I
just forgot
no Michael Adams and he was saying that
that we always have to keep in mind when
we are making decisions that there be
more important decision to come so we
have to keep our time for for the more
important later decisions no that's very
true you can't spend all your time when
the first important decision comes up
you have to kind of deal with your deal
with your future so so what if we move
on to a different game yeah let's go
back to the Camille dragon Alejandro
game this is our key matchup for group
Group B and things have gotten traded
and the position maybe seems a bit shaky
er for whites compared to the last time
we saw the
position the Knights have been traded if
we go back after 97 Queen d4 Knight f6
was actually white who went for the
knight exchange Knight to e4 trade on e4
and then Pawnee five should keep in mind
even though the e pawn is a weak isolate
pawn it's also a passed pawn so it might
be a weapon for black later on in the
game given it is supported by the rook
on the 8th and after King be one Queen
c3 brings us to the current position
where I don't know I liked white earlier
but now it seems relatively imbalanced
exactly I thought it we were impressed
how white played how its controlling the
board how the pieces are active how
everything is perfect and suddenly I
feel it may be actually the white king
that is in trouble let's say I play rook
f8 and rook f1 is a threat of a
checkmate so something White has to
figure out what to do and how to how to
proceed in this position we have to keep
in mind that black ace upon up that is
true though actually it's equal material
looks like box upon up but the pawns are
just separated with isolate pawn on e5
so I mean from a positional standpoint I
do still like whites
if Queens come off the board White has
everything to play for
but Alejandra is not going to trade off
Queens if he's not forced to and in the
meantime you know why it has some some
scary issues to face on the back rink
black has a very simple plan and what to
do for white in this position wanna see
two tricked me I didn't I didn't see it
at all but what to do it right here
I mean Ken can you try to maybe capture
the pawn on a six so let's first protect
the rook with the move Queen e2 Queen e2
just seems a bit passive maybe it's
playable I should note that black has
another idea in the position just move
the a pawn down the board try and get it
to a3 create some stagnating
possibilities on b2
so perhaps a5 could be played to give up
another pawn on d5 it is a pawn
sacrifice but so I will take it you take
the pawn
I just want to sacrifice everything can
i play a four here to open the a file
and I will take it you take that pawn
now your Queens a bit out of play can I
go for rook f8 going for the back rank
mates your work on d2 tied down to the C
pawn so I have to play something like
Queen f4 to make sure I'm defending the
C 2 square and freeing up the rook to go
back to D 124 and maybe the maybe my
play is a bit too reckless is black but
as a commentator I can maybe have fun
sacrificing some pawns I don't know if
the line is finished though after rook
f1 rook t1 rook f2 still trying to have
fun as black but maybe why it would have
the last bit of fun with 48 maybe you're
starting with Queen D 540 but I do like
your ideas I mean that's what the black
has to think about proceeding with the
pawns on the Queen side and trying to
threaten the king with some checkmating
Nats yeah so maybe black wants to
execute the pawn advance a bit more
slowly perhaps defend the b5 punt first
to enable a5 plan to run down the board
perhaps a move like rook c5 or even just
transfer the rook over it to f8 where it
would have more constant pressure and
given that the e5 pawn is defended by
blacks Queen perhaps this would be a
logical continuation
I agree another idea can be that if if
why indeed retreats the Queen e2 maybe
but I can push the pond so what did
black plays just before you four in this
position I mean yeah there's a saying in
chess passed pawns must be pushed and in
this case especially at a spawn defended
by the rook why not push it it just goes
to show that white might need to
blockade this this pawn on the e-file
given that it's a constant worry in the
position the power got to eat were to
get to e3 it could be a somewhat of a
headache for for white and we do have to
know that we have a result in Group B we
see Kings in the middle of the center
players are out Sam
Savion drew against vara Kobe on Sam 7
so that was Group A actually and that
was a key key matchup for the standings
in Group A seems like neither player
really got anything if we take a look at
the final position seems very dry not
completely symmetrical pawn structure
but really nothing for either side to
play for and since we are in Group A now
let's look at the game Yara's Arabic
against massive durable a the leader of
Group A yeah if a thief wins his game
he'll be much closer to to taking home
first place
and if we take a look at the current
position the Seif is currently up upon
going back how did he win upon looks
like the pawn on d4 it just was captured
we were looking at this position earlier
and we we mentioned this idea with
Queens it'd be eight but I don't think
we we saw this this simple capture on d4
so by black-white the kendama captured
what is happening there so I think the
idea after Knight takes d4 Queen take f2
forcing King h1 and perhaps a simple
queen takes e4 black is technically down
material here but I mean look at the
problems for white the bishop on d2
attacked also possibilities of Knight f2
I do want to show the full line just for
the maybe lesser experienced viewers who
are watching if the bishop were to move
in this position let's say Bishop to f4
black has a classic smother meeting idea
after Knight f2 King g19 h3 King h1 and
then the various death at Queen g1 rook
takes you 1 and I take F to check mates
every professional chess player has
learned this from probably very early on
in their their chess careers so Rudy for
a very interesting move I mean we Nova
CV is a very active player and and we
see the game just wait a minute a thief
lost what happened he he was up upon but
we didn't get to the current position
this is Miss Eve's first loss of the
tournament
after rook T for Bishop h6 was played
going for the mating attack not allowing
black town initiative Knight take h6 and
I take d4 so white just went out
material here so do you think that maybe
black missed the very storm of Bishop h6
where it distract the Black Knight and
then simply just recaptures the rook
it's a very nice resource in the
position Bishop h6 probably we we all
missed except except yarrow who found it
and the the power of Bishop h6 it does
deflect the night so after a night take
on d4 of white can safely win the
exchange without having to worry about
the f2 pawn and Wow I mean going forward
here white is just up the exchange and
yarrow converted with no trouble final
position ended with rook a8 and looks
like unstoppable threat against this
Bishop on f8 so we have many results in
the group a so maybe we'll soon get
graphics and see what are the standings
but before that let's look at the game
Benjamin Bach and Peter Prohaska yeah
let me find that game Peter per Houska
we had this root end game saying how
Benjamin is may be happier for having
some control of the C file so how is the
position looking now yeah pun certainly
got traded and if we take a look at the
current position white did manage to win
this pawn on c6 but black one the black
is seems to be about to win the pawn in
e2 so I mean any thoughts about this
position I probably still have to prefer
white given that white is currently up
to pawns in the position so we can we
can expect rook takes a two I mean we
see black still thinking about his game
about his move but I don't feel like you
have a better move than recapturing the
pawn yeah I mean you have to win pawns
back at some points but now it's White's
move and white can perhaps exert some
some pressure on black having extra pond
in the position especially this extra
pawn and therefore makes a king side a
bit safer
perhaps some idea like rook c7 with
intention of Queen to f5 seems very
pleasant for light this is the this is
the kind of position where white will
play for results for two more maybe two
more hours just moving around with the
pieces maybe trying to play something
like f5 f6 to break breaking on the
kingside but really just moving around
and seeing and maybe waiting for blacks
mistakes I think this is the kind of
very pleasant position that you can have
if you are white that's actually a
really good point I do like this this
plan of lunging the left on forward and
maybe it can even may play it in this
position pawn on f5 going for a simple
advanced point f6 and this is this is
what you want to do when you have the
extra pawn you you want to make full use
of extra pawn and if white can get the
pawn to f6 it may be very weakening -
relaxing side so we will wait how what
do I decide here and let's look at the
standings for group a yeah we have a few
results still done a couple games still
pending but after the loss today Wasif
Tarr Bailey is now tied for first place
with version the Cobian version Akopian
drew is came today so both players will
be going into tomorrow's round tied for
first and Sam Savion right behind with
five points so the determine is going to
come down to around nine and tomorrow we
will have super important games Barocco
be on against Daniel Friedman and
vassakara Bailey against Sam Savion and
we will see if there will be a playoff
or not that's true I know we're all
looking forward to what will hopefully
be a very exciting playoff in the final
day well let's move on let's take a look
at the games which are still going
scrolling through here the Jeffrey John
game is still going on against Alexander
in ditch a lot of material has come off
the board let's go back and see how the
Knights got traded because we were a bit
perplexed with this position earlier
White's not on d6 did not did not
survive the next several moves after h6
Queens III and then we see this simplify
Asian tactic with rook taking five and
material is coming off the board
Alexander did save his night on from d6
going to f5 creating some threats
against the Kings side I think Ben
Feingold loves to say knife f5 as a
knight on an f5 can be a very dangerous
attacking piece but Geoffrey had no
worries here after Queen f6 everything
for the most part is defended after 90
gauge six things simplify the bit the
Knights did get traded and rook c1
played
I'm counting material here Black is up a
pawn but I mean white can simply take
the pawn on d5 I can see that was just
played moves are coming pretty quickly
here and black recaptured the rook white
captured the rook and probably black
will take the pawn on h4 we just
happened so Geoffrey is having a safe
healthy pawn up but we have a queen and
game and porn app may not be enough for
for win but either way black is
bear-like is having a very pleasant
position that's true and I do want to go
to the this game against between
Daenerys aduba cassava and Sergei Motte
Cinco things did seem to be heating up a
ton I mean look at this position rook to
c1 white has a huge mating attack Queen
h6 looming what to do for black in this
position we can imagine if something
like rook take a three is played it's
just going to be a mating attack for
white rook c8 98 rook to e8 this is very
very bad for black so what to do after
rook c1 maybe the trade of rooks after
rook takes he won Queen take c1 but
Queen see it is still looming Queen h7
is looming White has two different ways
to checkmate the King via the back rink
or via the h7 pawn so can't be happy and
Sergey Mont Saint goes position here and
I mean he is towards the top of the
leaderboard in Group B so there is some
some worry for him if he does go down in
this game
he's not gonna be fighting for the top
spots in the final round and look at his
time advantage I mean less than two
minutes on the clock so I feel like this
is going to be very decisive in de
Nora's favor but I do want to move on we
do have a special guest in the studio
welcome
Yara's arabic after defeating vas Easter
Bailey giving him the first loss of the
tournament congratulations thank you so
I do want to ask you about this game in
terms of opening preparation I I'm sure
you've played the Seif many times before
giving you guys to lead to chess and
both in the protest League against rival
teams
so is this an opening that you were
expecting before the game oh yeah
because he played a grim fold the whole
tournament he was very successful at it
so yeah of course I was expecting it but
move 785 was already booked so I mean
not a very deep prep by me actually to
be honest I haven't prepped plenty of my
games here I just for this game I just
like oh grunt fault I'll play c3 okay
whatever this uh-huh you know so I mean
yeah so you can definitely tell I wasn't
right can you explain that approach
because there's a high level tournament
like this you expect the players to be
preparing very hard for every game just
maybe not preparing for the games give
you some more energy going into them
well yeah I mean I can well one of the
reasons why I haven't perhaps like a lot
for my games because I've been I have a
lot of other stuff going on and I feel
like if I prep for the game I'll be just
like completely exhausted and plus I
have some chest lessons in the evenings
you know and I'm like no that is like
way too my chest so and plus I haven't
been prepped I've been prepping
something for the US Championship so you
know I still kind of remember it so it's
useful
I mean yeah on the bad approach just to
save energy you can and get away be
fresh for the game yeah let's go forward
here because the seefs play was a bit
unusual especially this this rook
maneuver rook a6 and well you know I
couldn't guess any of his
probably he can guess any of my moves
I mean I'm not particularly proud of the
quality of the game to be honest it's
just like we played a you know like
roulette you know he didn't he bet on
the Reds and they bet on black and you
know it's like coin to us pretty much
I understand I mean I guess I should
have been better but then he found this
Queenie to move like after all of these
complications and I think just about it
equal balance position I think I play it
all right till some point the Queen c7
I've noticed there was a blunder yeah
you can place in the game was out of the
blunder
so yeah instead of Queen c7 95 was the
normal move and then I I wasn't sure I
probably can't win this because like in
the line 95 de rock a for Roque for
Bishop a4 there should be seven he has
queen b5 I believe that's what I
calculated so I kind of rejected this
and like if Queen c8 I calculated
further queen c8 I'm not sure if it's
all fine but Queen e5 Bishop h6 and our
queen e8 and he just holds everything
together
Bishop e8 is also fine actually it
doesn't really matter but Queenie 8 is
the most precise probably and just draw
so I decided to take some risk and then
after Queen c7 I noticed he probably
complain 93 I get 93 and the Queen d7
then 91 I guess and I'm just busted oh
wow you don't have a pawn oh but I'm not
sure how am i busted after rook e1 so I
mean instead of Queen d7 and
counter-attacking
yeah I'm not sure but don't you rate
showed me that somehow it was like
completely lost for white or really it's
not quite sure how but but you know I
tend to trust computers in such
positions of course it's all engine just
but there are things
yeah if it's not a positional stuff then
yeah yeah somehow so home somehow I'm
busted here and how lucky 193 rookie 1
yeah and here I was pretty happy after
he basically that's what I calculated
rookie one Quinn b5 Bishop d2 and then I
think I have like she's some sort of
psychological initiative his pieces all
dis coordinated my king is very safe you
know maybe it's not so easy for him to
adjust to new reality is that now I'm
the one who's pushing for the initiative
you know because previously he was
attacking me and all looked very nice
for him but oh it's very hard when
momentum shifts during a game sure and
go from being better to being worse
sometimes that can lead to more blunders
yeah and here I think you just collapsed
somehow maybe maybe because of the time
trouble but he blunder it quite a lot
well was Rick take tea for just a simple
wonder I might think so I mean well but
I already was happy about my position of
the Queen b8 because you know I I didn't
really see how he can defend here if
rook c8 and Queen b7 Bishop c6 and I
thought Queen Queen v1 is interesting
but all I thought maybe Queen b3 and
there should be five and just queen d1
Bishop g5 t5 yeah and maybe holding yeah
and then just h3 oh well in the another
line was instead of Queen b3 at Queen B
one Queen h5 and now each for pro like
this lass although still looks pretty
safe for me and you know when maybe next
move is just something like 95 or
something you know I I think I should be
better here so I was happy about the
position was after work before I think
is just outright blunder enough to
Bishop h6 it feels like it just seems
like I should be winning although kind
of hiss but definitely decided to speed
up the process
I mean negative three Bishop c6 and he
probably just blundered through k1 and
rook e8 idea so but this is technically
it was out light square bishop this is
like you know no chance for black really
no light square bishop so you can't hold
this like human Brooke Knight versus
rook I mean dark square bishop in the
night it's like completely lost so
that's right it just seems pretty
hopeless for life yeah so so yeah I mean
it's good that I finished the game
before 6:00 because I have a class at
6:00 so you're you you're teaching this
tournament no no no I have a college
yeah University class my this today is
the first day of my summer semester
oh well best of luck for the summer
semester my final one so how is it
balancing school and academics I know
you you're playing for the st. Louis
University chess team is it difficult to
balance two very different disciplines
same time that's really cuz I just take
it easy you know I mean when I have time
I do school when I don't have time I
play chess yeah well it seemed sound z'
like your very busy person won't keep
you any longer best of luck in the final
round nope thank you and we're gonna
take a quick break and we'll be back
with more coverage of the 2018 summer
just classic a moment comes in chess
when you need to test yourself at a
different level chess 24 premium offers
the tools that you need to reach your
maximum potential from hundreds of
interactive video lessons to becoming
part of the chess 24 community you can
analyze with friends or coach your
students live you get twenty four by
seven coverage of chest news and events
access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get it bashed from the best
and even challenge them to a battle be
the best chess player you can be it's
time to level up your game with just 24
Premium Membership this August the best
chess players in the world are coming to
st. Louis with a grand chest tour
st. Louis rapid and Blitzen Sinquefield
Cup tournaments will feature the world's
best right here in st. Louis
st. Louis chess club's celebrating its
10th anniversary and these tournaments
will be a highlight you won't want to
miss for tickets and more information go
to st. Louis chess club org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to this 2018
summer chess classic I'm international
master Eric Rosen joined by women's
Grand Master Kettering and Silva welcome
back how yurina thank you so maybe let's
look at the games in the group a yeah we
have some fights still going on and some
interesting end games which could lead
to some very very long fights let's
start with a game between Benjamin Bach
and Peterborough Aska where we saw Peter
had a nice positional game earlier
better structure the position has
liquidated liquidated a bunch into well
now we have a four-on-three rook ending
where I know Peter had this a similar
type of situation the other day against
version of Kobe and he did not manage to
win what do you think the odds are of
white converting this position I know
that the rule is if let's say the pawn
on f4 is on e4
then black ruler has to push immediately
h5 to try to prevent white from
expanding and forcing and wanting to
force some trade and now when I see the
ponies on f4 I feel this should be
drawing so I should not be able to
create a a pawn that is dangerous for
black eye my prediction is that this is
going to be draw I think this is just
probably going to be a dead draw there
on move 39 so after one more move each
side will get half hour or more as white
you you probably have to push given that
you do have extra pawn and there are
chances for the opponent to go wrong but
in this sort of situation it's very
difficult for a white to even create a
passed pawn especially with these
double-a plans so let's maybe move on to
the Alex on innate in Geoffrey showing
game because there is also a pawn up but
instead of rooks we have Queens and that
brings more chances for black to two
you win this game oh this is a end game
which I'm sure the the players have
studied in the past a very common
scenario where it's just the Queen
ending with a pawn majority on one side
the plan is very simple for Joffrey just
keep advancing the Queen side pawns
probably eventually go for this b3 push
create the pass pawn the only worry for
black is the safety of the King and
whites best drawing chance is some
opportunity with perpetual check but as
we see now white cannot make any chance
because we have a very active Queen on
c4 and and the King looks actually safe
for now and 87 so I expect a very very
long game we have to know that players
just made move 40 so they are getting
extra 30 minutes long game ahead yeah
and we should point out Alexander in
judge this time does say zero zero zero
I don't think he's flagged given how the
players are very focused on the position
I'm sure 30 minutes will be added to his
clock very shortly but I do like the
this idea for black with the Queen on c4
a lot of these squares are under control
the King on h7 seems very safe I mean if
that needs to he can play g6 and
meanwhile the Queen on c4 also defends
this f7 pawn so I don't know if it's
gonna be a quick fight I think Geoffrey
might take this one home if white can't
stir up any immediate counter play I
remember when I was studying in Texas
Brownsville we were playing out these
positions where one side has only one
extra pawn it's a queen endgame and I
remember it was always very difficult
for the weak side to really always find
the best moves to to keep the chance
alive to keep it drawing drawing lines
possible so I feel even if at some
moment maybe it's we have a you know
draw position where white can hold it's
very difficult to keep doing the good
moves and keep the draw
well that's true so we'll have to keep
an eye on this game see if Geoffrey can
actually convert his advantage I do want
to go to a game that's actually finished
in Group B but had a really nice finale
of the game between Daenerys to do a
Kosova and Sergey Monsanto
Norma played some incredible attacking
chess and the final position is a bit
funny featuring a queen sacrifice I was
taking a look at this position before
the interview with yarrow and rook c1
was played and seemed like Sergei was
very desperate with the black pieces he
went for this pawn advance pawn g5
attacking the Queen on f4 and dinara
very calmly just captured the rook on c3
with the idea that if white goes down
the Queen not so fast
rook c8 would come and this is just
completely winning for whites very nice
active game
I wonder if dinara is playing for the GM
title because if she wins in the last
round I really she has some chances to
to claim a normal now she's playing very
great fighting justice tournament and
that's one thing we haven't talked about
much the norm possibilities for the
players
yesterday I was wondering if Tata
Abraham Ian was in contention for an
iron or him when I talked to Tata after
the the round yesterday and she informed
me that she has maybe a dozen IM norms
and she's just needing that a 2400 feed
a rating so now dinara maybe for the
team title going but let's look at
another game I thought camel dragon
Alejandra Ramirez we have another rook
and game is there a draw or who's
playing for advantage yeah we were
seeing this position earlier with Queens
on the board and with Queens on the
board black had some some active play
maybe some attacking ideas but Queens
are now traded and I think White has
everything to play for especially with
this rook on e7 I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if white just puts both rooks
on the 7th rank this is a very
fundamental endgame concept you want
your looks as active as possible in this
case I like to call it 7 heaven where
the rooks are just in heaven just
dominating blacks blacks territory and
maybe for less less experienced players
we can show an interesting line so let's
say white goes for this strong move Ruby
d7 to dominate on the 7th rank and black
wants to defend the pawn on g7 and fight
Group g6
now why does a very strong move rook da
toruk eh checkmating actually the kink
yeah that's the nature of the rooks on
the seventh not only do they thread to
win pawns but there's all these threats
of back rank mate
so maybe black would have to play the
the counter-attacking move rook to f1
forcing king b2 and then rook f2 trying
to get some seven heaven of himself or
in this case second heaven I should say
and wide if he goes for the trade so
let's play it out
so Brooke take G fades and there's no
check on f7 meanwhile black is just
guaranteed to win the C pawn so maybe
not so simple for whites so let's say Y
takes on eight seven now we have to be
worried about the last about the
background checkmate either rook h8 or
Ruby is a threat for a checkmate but
blanket Summa contra attacking chances
so let's say rook C takes c2 but the
king can the king just run away King a3
Brooke take a - King before I think
white would be escaping here and black
would be in big trouble so I would I
would really like to play after King a
3-2 moves to make a 5 first to trap you
there and make a checkmate unfortunately
there would not be that would not be
possible but I can wait with capturing
on a2 and maybe I can move my King to g8
or yet to just make sure I'm not getting
checkmated
yeah that's may be the last chance for
black but a move like kingi aides could
walk into the very simple brook a7 and
with the rooks so far separated brook a
eights or rook h8 our threats and I
don't see blacks reviving this position
so let's let's be king BG egg I feel
that that is a more natural mover we are
still attacking the rogue and making
sure that we cannot get the checkmate it
immediately so let me actually just show
some instructive ideas here I actually
gave a video for the st. Louis chess
club a few months back it's called pigs
on the seventh rank the rooks being
compared to pigs in this case showing a
lot of different checkmating ideas in
these sort of scenarios
white would have the the very forcing
rook g7 check
King f8 and then rook a7 going for these
same ideas and if King g8 black or white
could just very simply move the rook
across the board going as far away as
possible from the lac King and trying to
create some some attack on the back rank
we see this advantage of being first on
the seventh or second rank because you
are the one who has extra 10-point can
create more more mating threats so what
is Black has some issues to deal with
luckily by guess 30 minutes and he has
he can calculate what is the what is the
biggest chance for him to to hold on to
a draw yeah I mean going back to the
current position Camille is taking his
time I'm curious if he's considering a
different move than rook d7 maybe first
delivering the check on d8 and then
playing roti 7 but I wouldn't be
surprised if we see some some similar
lines play odds so we can move on to the
king Tata Fabri ham ham and raised to
copying we saw some knight and rook and
games they're crazy tactical battle not
to mention it's deep in that game we saw
the pawn race scenario earlier White's
pawn has reached all the way to a 7 but
now it's being blockaded by the rook on
AIDS and black is up is up a pawn here
not saying the pawn count is too
relevant but these three connected
passed pawns and everything well
defended for black
I like Andres chances to win this game I
must say did I do like the knight on
these three defending the f2 and f4
square us and kind of blocking the King
to maybe come come closer to the pawn on
g3 but now the pawn on
h7 on a 7 / me is attacked
so what white can do can white go maybe
four Knights e5 Knight c5 definitely
unmoving the position and then it's a
question where does box King move King
is tied down to the fang the rooks I
believe black would be forced to play a
move like king f4
so 95 can get for it still has to worry
about this pawn on a7 simply being being
attacked and not defended and meanwhile
it just seems like White's pieces aren't
coordinated like that I don't see 5 it
is towards the center but it's not doing
much to to benefit white in the position
so let's say I go with another check 93
I mean it is a difficult situation it
seems that right doesn't have that many
troubles because the pawn a 7 is very
advanced but it's not supported and
doesn't have enough pieces to to try to
force it to go to the 8th ranked yeah
after 93 I probably go for a king f5
making sure the Knights can't check the
King and at least immediately and I
think it's white having a lot of issues
to deal with this is a very difficult
situation for white and looks like a
pleasant one for black I do want to move
on to a game that's finished in Group B
Robert August re and drawing Vladimir
Bellis in what seemed to be a
hard-fought game from the final position
we were discussing from the other game
the rooks on the seventh coming to life
if we see how the game ended after rook
take b3 rook F take f7 it seems like
white has advantage here but maybe there
was nothing to play for after rook g3
white gave some checks and I think white
White's on nothing more than a draw we
do have to know black is threatening
some counter play with I move like rugby
too and also the pawn on g4 is hanging
so even if white gets back to defend the
g2 black and simply capture the pawn on
g4 and they say this is a draw so
definitely some some hard-fought games
today and some games with overlapping
themes we saw this theme earlier with
the light landing on d6 some themes of
rooks coming to the seventh or second
rank in the endgame which came to move
on to I would like to see what's
happening here the game Ike Sandra
Indian Geoffrey Zhang Hao is Geoffrey
playing for a win with extra pawn queen
and game
seems like Jeffrey has made some
progress if we go earlier the pawns are
just racing down the queenside every
move after pawn a3 pawn b5 and Inge is
just kind of forced to be passive here
just kind of wave around not the most
enjoyable plan for such position just to
do nothing and let your opponent
continually make progress we also can
know that there are tricks like Queen b3
for black to play now and what is unable
to go to exchange the Queen's because
the pawn is simply promoting for another
Queen
yeah Queen b3 of course white can't
trade on b3 maybe what could could use
some geometry here with the open
position go for a queen h5 attack the
King after King g8 defend from a more
active score on c5 and it's still a
question how black is breaking through
and also managing to have some some
safety for the King on g8 and why does
some perpetual check chances here with
Queen CA and Queen h3 to maybe keep
attacking the King and forcing a draw so
but it has to be careful about not maybe
giving up too many files and moving away
the Queen and making sure that I am
advancing slowly yeah just to
demonstrate outline like if I were to go
for the immediate break through here
with a move like b4 we can even see
white I can take the pawn and after a
three Queen CA check not entirely sure
if black can escape these series of
checks after Queen h3 the King would
have to run or in front of the pawns and
it seems a bit difficult for black in
this position to actually escape the
checks so let's try to predict the move
that Geoffrey is gonna make it couldn't
be three it's not that correct what else
can we do if we are black we can do
something like g6 to make sure we are
defending the h5 square I do like g6 I
mean why not there's there's no hurry in
this position black has all the time in
the world to make progress why not play
and
we move stock Queen h5 and always have
to keep this in mind f7 is defended so
white really doesn't have a much of a
target to attack in this position
another idea can be Queen efore just
trying to improve the Queen put it more
in the center and see how white is gonna
react to this check that's another
strategy in these positions just play a
move which makes your opponent think and
I know I've mentioned this before but if
you can continually force your opponent
to make decisions you can get them low
enough on time or maybe you can provoke
some blunder later on yes sometimes I'm
analyzing positions like this with my
students and they are saying how do I
have in such a position and I'm like
just make a move and see what your
opponent is going to do sometimes you
don't have a direct plan sometimes you
just want to improve your position and
maybe give a chance for your opponent to
make a blunder or make a mistake or show
you how you can go and improve your
position that's true
I do want to take a look at the matchup
so far in Group A we do have many
results taking place I believe only two
games still pending with Alexander in
jet playing Jeffrey Zhang and the only
other game Peter Prohaska against
Benjamin Bach maybe we can switch gears
and take a look at the the Benjamin
knocking given that many moves have been
played but I don't see much progress
being made for white in this position we
discuss this position we thought it's
gonna finish and draw soon I think
that's still the case I think they are
gonna agree on a draw and let me ask you
a fun question here I know I've asked
you this question about previous
positions earlier in this tournament but
let's imagine you have the block pieces
against Magnus Carlsen how confident are
you that you could draw against the one
and only Magnus I think saying that
you're gonna draw a position against
Magnus that's so both I I don't know
that I I would do it in a same color
Bishop endgame that maybe maybe choice
because sometimes you are just worried
that these players can think about magic
that you don't see so III don't know how
confident I would be but I do think this
should
this should be a draw I think it would
take actual actual magic to win this
position is white given I mean what's
the breakthrough I think the only idea
to consider is something like h3g for
the black has everything under control
well I think white can try to go maybe
rook a to rook a six to see what you're
gonna do about your King and then slowly
but surely move the pawns up yeah that
even if I've just waits on the square
like g7 I mean I think it's just a
waiting game for black and when the
pawns advance there will be trades and
there shouldn't be too much life for
white in this position and we have some
moves in the game I saw in the Jeffrey
jean game g6 indeed happened and Alex
and I choose g4 movie guys which I
thought is rather surprising I like the
idea of putting the ball on g5 and maybe
having some control of the squares
around the King so we can go for for
perpetual check but it seems so
weakening I mean this is actually a very
typical idea in these sort of Queen pawn
and games where one side is up the pawn
white actually shouldn't care too much
about the safety of the King all white
cares about is exposing the black King
so if white can lunge the pawns forward
trying maybe initiate some trade maybe
we'll see you some idea like King g3 f4
f5 it's all about exposing the black
King and creating some some drawing
chances with some eventual professional
check so I'm curious how this game gonna
unfold that if I was black I would play
something like Queen f4 and just waiting
to see how what is your next move
because you do have to make sure you are
not going to lose the pawn on g4 and my
simple idea is to break through on the
Queen side when I can just to play
before mm-hmm I mean so lots to play for
in this game I do want to go to another
game in Group B with Camille dragon
against Alejandra Ramirez because I'm
being told that Camille could possibly
clinch victory today if he's able to win
the game not sure if we have a graphic
for the the results so far so far in
Group B
but I mean it seems like things are
going Camille's way there's only two
games pending so far with Camille having
the advantage against Alejandro Mira's
Daenerys to do a cassava defeating Andre
mots anko and that that eliminates Andre
from from actually it's not Andres not
saying go so her game on saying go
eliminates him from from coming back to
try and clinch victory and with the
draws between Josh Vidal JJ Ally Morandi
and Robert Haga sorry and Larry
marvelous I'm pretty sure Camille can
clinch first place with a win we should
take a look at the standings we can see
a pretty big gap between Camille and the
rest of the field
yeah if Camille wins his game still
pending he would get six points I guess
that just leaves two copán who could
catch up if spook open wins today he
would have five points going into
tomorrow so there's some speculation
here if Andre and Camille win there will
be the two players fighting for first
place in the final game tomorrow we have
to know that it's very interesting
Daenerys Erika so ah she's tied for the
second place so far she is she's she
started as ranked 9 in this tournament
so she's thinking very well here we
talked about maybe her chances for
getting a GM norm but they're not a very
nice tournament for her yeah very
impressive play by Jinora so far and a
lot of her games have been so instructed
like very direct attacking chess her
wind against Alejandra Ramirez sure
Alejandro not pleased with me bringing
this up but it was a pretty stellar
victory and her game today against her
game at Cinco I mean just very
impressive play so let's look back at
the game Tata Abraham iam against Andres
to copying we had some chance if we
could Black has some advantage there so
how it's now we don't see too many moves
being played yeah well both players got
the extra time after move 40 it's
currently moved 43 rook-a for just
played by Tata it's Andres move
and I have to favor Andre in this
position even though this pawn in a7 is
a bit annoying I feel like that's blacks
massive passed pawns and the King side
should be even more annoying it's just a
question how does black actually make
progress in this position I think that's
a very important question because visual
opposition can be appealing but then we
need to see how we actually can advance
that advantage and maybe change it to
win because I see you plan for white
where I can try to play 97 and 96 to
force the route from AAA to get away and
then promote our pawn so black has to
try something similar maybe black has
idea with Knight e3 then g2 and rook F 1
it's very true and it's blacks move
which should give some advantage to
black being or meaning time is very very
important in this sort of situation 93
night to e3 looks incredibly logical
hitting the rook on g2 forcing it to
move away and allowing the Jeep on to
advance maybe we can play this out and
see how the game could transpire let's
say saber of g1 assume you just want to
play g2 right
I was thinking actually if we just go
back with Luke jiwon if I can play York
a3 rook a3 in this position after 93
very small I want to pin deny but there
is a very strong move knight Knight c4
were just c4 charge as simple tactics
right we see I mean this is an endgame
but we still have to be careful about
some tactical tricks because the black
pieces are active the White King is
exposed and the knight is a very tricky
piece to to be attacking with yeah so if
Knight e3 is played rook a three out of
the question I do want to see what's
happening in this line after rook g1
let's say pawn G - it seems like black
is a bit quicker here I do have to play
a move like bouquet one okay one other
Brooke how do you want to actually very
multi-purpose supporting the pawn
perhaps discouraging rook f1 and it
still
question-how is black making further
progress in the position
maybe there's a nice move Knight c4
check and where is the king going I
thought I can go Queen King gay - but
then they're simply rook take a seven
and black is winning so what has to be
very careful so what is another movie
that I can do after Knight e3 and I see
that Knight e3 happened in the game so
white is suddenly thinking what to what
to do here it may be just a lost
position I really like 93 not only is it
supporting the G plan advance there's
all these all of these looming ideas of
Knight c4 check which could be very
annoying for for white in the position
meanwhile I'll talk to his time is
ticking down as tated at the board don't
see talked about the board I actually do
have an idea here so after rook t1 ok
taught of his back at the board writing
down her move maybe she was taking a
last chance coffee break before she has
to stay at the board for the rest of the
game so what's your idea so let's play
rook T 1 G 2 and now I will just try to
go for a counter-attack I'll go with
9797
sometimes the best defense is offense
I'm going for offense as well work f11
is happening I have to take Luke take is
G 2 now the pawn on the second ring
sometimes more valuable than a rook
afternoon I take G - I see your idea 19
b6 I assume yes we might actually see
this game go on for much much longer
we're back basically has to do the same
thing if I'm not mistaken
rook take a seven rook take a 7 and the
past pawns
they're the dangerous passed pawns have
come off the board but the resulting
position black having to connected
passed pawns
I think we're here
but Knights are tricky and black would
have to be still careful to transfer
this this
advantage into a full point right so
definitely a game to keep our eyes on
the current position taught to play rook
to g1 Andre still pondering his next
move perhaps considering the lines that
we've been talking about but maybe
seeing more than us so what is happening
in the game of Geoffrey Zhang I'm very
curious to see how the Queen's how the
Queens are being played but there's a
pawn up well we finally have a pawn
break in the Geoffrey John game we can
see b4 has been played
Geoffrey walking away from the chair a
sign that maybe he's comfortable with
with what's gonna happen over the next
few moves black will very soon have a
passed pawn on the Queen side and should
also note that Geoffrey did play this g6
move creating a lot of a lot of safety
for the the King on h7 I have to say I
do like to be for move immediately going
for going for a promotion with the a
pawn I think what I've written I the g4
move I know that you thought did you say
that it's a good move to control the
squares but I feel it's it's a huge
weakness in the white can yeah I'm
trying to figure out some some path
forward for white I mean seems like
white has to take the pawn after Queen
take before and now it's a big question
can wait
get play against the black King before
black can just score a touchdown with
his 8th pawn outline like Queen d7
doesn't seem to be too promising because
the black Queen can find a very nice
square on b3 and I mean the a pawn just
marching down the board the Queen on b3
supporting the a pawn and defending f7
seems like Alexander has to go all out
to create some idea I'm not sure if any
ideas exist for whites and another idea
for black may be after before and
context before maybe black does not have
to recapture the pond maybe after pawn
takes before but I can just push a3 a3 I
mean maybe a few good options for black
given that opponent before and not a
nuisance in the position and when a 2 is
played the white is uh it's pretty much
lost so now that bad idea but we'll
an eye on that game we should focus our
attention to Group B because first
places on the line and I think we're
gonna stay with with these games until
we know whether or not Camille dragon
has clinched first place in the
tournament we can see the line that we
were discussing earlier is playing out
with with seven heaven for a light let's
actually go back to review
Camille did play rook da check first but
I don't think too much changes after
rook DD 7 rook F 1 and white is scooping
up the pawns on the seventh rank and
Alejandro's move a Camille away from the
board Alejandra can't be too happy given
that black doesn't seem to have any sort
of perpetual check and again white has I
mean one is why these two pawns app can
attack the King on the back rank this is
such a pleasant position for white such
a difficult difficult position for
Alejandro Oh as black I would like to
maybe shift the a pawn up one square
when the opponent's not looking of
course that would uh that would never
happen but if black's pawn was on the a5
then this idea with rook take c2 could
be a lot powerful creating this this
mating idea if the king ever comes to a3
unfortunate for Alejandra the pawn is
not on a5 and now he has to figure out
how to proceed in the position I assume
he's going to take the pawn and c2 it's
just a question of which rook to capture
with but things do not seem too
promising for him I thought it maybe we
can start with the kimchi I just to make
sure we are not in checkmate immediately
and then recaptured upon so let's try to
play it out but taking GG it happens so
we should also keep in mind even if
white isn't mating in this position
white is up to pawns so white white has
a few winning ideas why could either go
for mating attack or just trade off a
pair of rooks and be out material as
white I would go for the same idea of
rook rook to g7 King f8 and then
bringing the rook all the way back to a7
not only going after another undefended
but going for Rock AIDS with with me so
I would go back again King tiara I mean
it's kind of for us I do have to keep
the rook attack I do have to keep in
mind the checkmate on the back rank so
here at least I have the F file free so
the rook on f2 okay can I get back on f8
and protect the king that that is true
as white I'll just continue with my plan
rook H to b7 if I'm not meeting you at
least I'm trading rooks and probably
winning the pawn on on a6 so now I
tagged upon rook see takes you to I mean
I have to take that bond as well even
though it may not be enough actually
when you take the pawn you're forcing
the king to move up the board I move
like King B to a result in perpetual
check for black so I would be forced to
play king a3 so I take another pawn you
take another pawn I run the King and
it's actually equal material but I feel
I feel like white is still the one to to
be pushing for some advantage in this
position so let's say I now pushed up on
e4
I mean I that's the only one that can do
something stressful it's not like I have
too many choices here yeah Pawnee for
and now I guess it's a question what
does white do in the position because
maybe the line with trading rooks isn't
entirely clear a line like rook to b8
rook F fades rook take f8 King take off
eight black actually has everything
covered but a pawn could be annoying
this pawn is attacked on H - maybe this
is alejandra this drawing chance in the
position I see he'd just play the move
looks like he captured the pawn with the
seabrooke's so he didn't start with King
G aids but it's possible the line could
transpose into what we're looking at
let's go to the current position Camille
doesn't have too many options here I
think he has to play king a3 if he wants
to play for a win maybe just double
checking these lines just making sure
he's not elucidating upon still is on a6
not on a5 so black and take upon here as
well just to take room takes a to
forcing the King to go to before and now
way with da King maybe King g8 yeah King
gee it looks like we're gonna get us a
very similar position maybe the same
position with just a transposition and
can we expect ok moves are coming pretty
rapidly rook a to played and then King
to be four and Alejandro playing King g8
so we we were predicting the future in
this game so King King t8 is it has
happened now planners do have 20 minutes
so they are just like playing quickly
because they see they think it's obvious
Oh King g8 happened as well we are happy
we are having the position that we just
analyzed right and here I mean I think
we can expect rook dg7 King f8 rook a 7
going into the line that we were
discussing and the big question can
white play for anything more than just
just to draw in King g8 rook HB 7 then
you wanted to play just why not move
efore makes sense it's really not too
many there are no other chances for
Blagdon than E 4 but I do want to stay
with this game but I saw that we have
new moves in the game Tata Abraham Ian
and Andres - copying but moves that we
did not predict that's right and this is
another key game for the standings in
Group B if Andre wins his game he'll
still be in contention to catch up to
Camille no matter what happens in
Camille's game and it looks like Andre
should be closer to converting the
position at the g2 idea which rook F 1
but entre decided to to play Okafor
instead to make sure that the rook on a
4 is no longer active maybe black wants
to trade it so then the ponente for a7
can be just captured mm-hmm I am being
told Jeffrey jean has won his game
against Alexander in Jets which we were
expecting a final position looks a
little unusual you can see neither
player at the board currently let's just
take a look at the current position
standings are not important for this
game
going back just to show the endgame
technique by Jeffrey let's go back
further
what happened g4 b4o Queen take 84 I
don't think we we actually saw this move
a for pun was hanging but after Queen
take G for black is able to continually
check the King maneuver the Queen to a
desired location after Queen d6 check
beautiful move of attacking the king and
also supporting the the pawn to capture
on 83 this is just completely waiting
for black very nice and important win
for Geoffrey who with this pawn point is
five out of eight so he's still still
going for the first place in the last
last round yeah so should we go back to
the Tata of Abraham Ian game against
Andres to copan where we left off
Tata thinking at the board there her her
time situation appears to be getting
worse and worse
she's just above 10 minutes Andre
sitting is a very comfortable 26 minutes
and I do really admire this move work
out for I think it's just a simple tempo
move white does not want to allow the
trade which would allow lack scheme to
activate and leave the pond and a7
undefended so white has to somehow avoid
the trade by moving the rook but where
does it go
so rue k5 would be a big blunder because
we would lose it immediately yeah we
should point out the the fork potential
these these squares on a3 and a5 are
off-limits due to the the lingering
Knight c4 check which means not too many
squares for the rook so let's see white
will play rook a6 that's a safe spot
you're moving away with the rook making
sure that we are still defending the
opponent a7 and keeping their chance of
moving to 97 96 and promoting the pawn
that's true and it would be box move
here I'm curious if Bach can just play
the simple double attack maybe rook c4
going after the c2 pawn with check also
attacking the undefended 9 on c5 do you
want to give up the pawn on t3
hmm so it does leave the g3 plan hanging
this move would probably require some
calculation if rotate g3 rook takes c2
King would have to move rook takes e5
the night comes off the board but maybe
the this final position rook a7 and
white can't defend the pawn
further so I I just thought it maybe
instead of king this is correct I think
this is just this is just lost for a
while but maybe if we just move the King
to be one instead of b3 so King b1 oh
maybe a nice nuance in the position
allowing the third-ranked
to be accessible to the to the rook
sometimes when calculating these long
variations you want to pay attention to
maybe the small differences between two
different options in this case after
rook takes e5 rook take III rook c7
could be met with rook a3 I would still
think there's some advantage for black
but maybe it would be quite annoying
upon very well defense we have to keep
in mind that the rook on a eight is
locked it it cannot be moved almost
almost never because then we will be
able to promote a pawn so what do you
think about this position can black
still play for a win given there are two
connected task pawns on the King side or
would this be whole double for white so
let's see why I mean blacks choice is to
go and advance the pawn so it's black
turn so let's say black place ePHI
that's a logical move now what kind of Y
to do I like to rock on c7 kind of
stopping the White King from from going
maybe and helping to prevent the
promotion of the pawns
so as if I'm white I play arooga
three-two to know where you are going
with it I would play King e for the
problem for a white in order to defend
the ape on you you need two rooks
defending at all times right so I just
go back you go back I keep pushing but
maybe I have to be a bit bit accurate
maybe King off for here
now I have through f6 we've got six King
g5 and I go back you go back f5 feel
like black can slowly but surely make
progress while white is kind of tied
down with all the pieces that's a
difficult situation so maybe I would I
would be okay of trading training the
pawns so maybe like group is six
somewhere here
rookie six in a position like this the
thing about rookie six is that after the
pawns got traded let's say you're up
take a seven I'll say that rooks got
traded in row taking five I think it's
still so far away that's that's the
element that I do not like in the whites
position now this isn't a game which I
teach most of my students this is maybe
a variation of the well-known move Cena
position where it's rook and pawn versus
rook but the white king is severely cut
off far away from the pawn this would
just be a technical way affair so let's
go back and see if there is a way for
whites to defend or if it's just lost
yeah maybe we can go back so we go back
to the Korean position or go back to
around here I think the four to seven
move 47 yeah around King b1 no might be
okay maybe a little more maybe back so
going back further this all came from my
suggestion just to give a refresher to
the viewers we're calculating the line
from the current position after oh you
know what a few moves have been played
seems like Tata allowed the rook trade
somewhat surprising let's refresh the
board get to the current position and
see how the game transpired after rook
f4 was plain Tata have just took the
pawn in g3 I mean she had very difficult
situation we saw that the rook c4 was a
threat black ass advantage there this is
another advantage for black maybe this
is just maybe it's winning for black and
what doesn't have a good choice yeah
maybe Tata she she was calculating the
lions she thought that mmm this doesn't
look too promising but maybe it's the
best chance so she went for it but now
we have a situation
two pawns four black one pawn for white
you have to favor Andre not only with
extra material but also at the time
advantage we have to say that the 44th
move
Ruka for was very strong very strong of
making sure that black is not going
directly for his attack with some g2 and
rook f1 but training the rooks and going
just for peaceful advantage in the
endgame
yeah very calm play by by Andre you have
to admire the endgame technique
especially among a lot of grandmasters
when they get a winning position
sometimes they they they gather grip and
they just hold on to it and I think this
is what we're seeing here
Andre taking no risks having the pawn
advantage and these two connected
pastors are going to be so much easier
to advance compared to the one passer
for white on the Queen side but you
never know Knights can be tricky and
there are some drawing chances for
White's the the first drawing
opportunity that comes to mind if Toph
can somehow sacrifice a night for both
of blacks pawns there are scenarios an
endgame where rook and Knight versus
alone rook would be a draw I agree
actually I draw this and game in a very
important game during my World Youth
Championship so White has a huge chances
to make a draw there but it's very very
stretched idea to to try to take the
pawns but sometimes that's all you can
do I mean you have already lost position
and you have to keep the hope and have
to try to do something in order to to
keep the chances for for not losing the
game that's true we can see one more
move played by taht of Knight to c5
trying to get some activity with the
night but now it's a matter for Andre
how to make progress on the King side
given these ponds are up casts but
they're not dangerous just yet
given their I mean the f7 pawn still
allows harding's for e six not too
dangerous it's a matter of of
coordinating the king of the rook in the
Knights allowing the pawns to advance
freely speaking about progress what if
we move on to the game of cameo Dragoon
hamed Ramirez and see what the progress
is there right we can see many more
moves have been played white white and
black having seven heaven and second
heaven but the heaven being slightly
more preferable from the white side
let's go back and see what happened
after King g8 rook dg7 King f8 rook a7
and now we see maybe a small wrinkle in
compared to what we were looking at
earlier I was suggesting work b7 going
as far away from the king as possible
Camilla went for the perhaps more
logical work you seven just keeping an
eye on the e pawn which is a potential
weakness in the position and now White's
rooks are beautifully placed given that
I mean there's constantly pressure
against both pawns I do have to say that
I like the Ruby 7 move because Flex idea
was to play E for III and go for
promotion and now I cannot do that right
now it's one more move has been played
actually after King to f8 there's been
looks like okay it's White's move now
the question is can white just safely
take the pawn or maybe white is
concerned about leaving the h2 pawn
undefended and sometimes the more cons
that come off the board the more Josh it
can be but what else to do for white it
doesn't seem like there's too many
options in the position we could maybe
imagine some move like rook b7 here
given the King on the faith there is
some a threats right against against the
black King pretty sure this would force
King g8 another question after King g8
is what if white goes for the traits and
white plays rook b8 forcing guru f8
captured on f8 King captures because now
the material is equal but we clearly see
that the rook on a 7 is very active is
cutting off the king the King on before
is very active and maybe white can push
the pawns on the King side but we do
have to be careful about the black pawn
on e5 as well because that point can run
around 2:00 it's another pond race
another major theme of today so the two
remaining games in Group B featuring
some interesting pong race scenarios and
we do have a move it was not rook p7
camille dragon going for the mediate
pawn h4 when you're in a race you you
don't want to waste any time you want to
go as quickly as possible and white now
has some ideas not only of queening the
pawn but perhaps using the pawn as a
helper to defend the rook on potential
g7 square and sometimes this could be a
sufficient enough to achieve checkmate
against the black king I wonder if black
can play here something like croak f3
rook f3 going after the Jeep on which is
currently not defend it also keeping an
eye on the b-pawn this looks fun to play
out let's say pawn h5 or actually I
wanted to start with not rogue after he
was starting with a 5 mm a 5 check so
giving up the be pawn and now Luke
afraid I got three things to keep in
mind that you cannot take on a 5 because
the rook on a 7 is still hanging and now
I do want to take on b3 so interesting
scenario here I would be inclined as
white to just keep pushing the H pawn I
am I am considering some other options
here let's say pawn h5 how to continue
so I can't capture on b3 King c4
now I wonder if I want to play rook
before or capture another pawn couple
options for black in this position we
can see a somewhat lack of coordination
between the black rooks and black can't
waste too much time here a given white
is very close to queening maybe even
considering walking the king and to
generate some meaning of you aren't you
in trouble so what if I go route before
King d5 now I go rook d2 chucks keep
coming roof d2 King e6 Luke b-66
let me find some shelter on f5 then I go
Luke I've to check rook F to King to g5
it's like a cat chasing a mouse like you
keep going after the mouse and mouse
keeps running away and finally it runs
to somewhere where there's some shelter
and it's all about finding shelter in
these positions where okay if white can
kind of be blanketed by the the passed
pawns on the Kings side maybe there's
some hope to to escape the checks and
win the game but now I'm also happy to
the King gets away from the Queen side
so I can push my pawn I can go a five I
can just run oh you mean pony 400
doesn't scare me too much I would just
go for h6
fifteen g5 okay eight six eight four
eight six yeah this point is too fast
and even like if you play rock h2h seven
coming doesn't look too promising for
black so maybe that were there was too
many checks but some chances like this
trying to break through in the Queen
side and make the rooks work together
and keep checking the King maybe that
can be an idea for black to go with can
we just switch gears for a moment let's
go back to the Tata of Abraham Ian
against Andres Duke open game a lot of
moves have been played Tata
again not with the best time situation
Knights have been traded but I can see
what happened how yeah should should
have allowed the nitrate but maybe she
was forced to after the very simple rook
c7 simply skewering the iron c5 and the
pawn and c2 and this is a problem for
white because but the knight does create
some drawing chances in the position but
after Knights getting traded I have a
feeling it's just going to be a
technical win for the black side having
the two extra plants
I mean 2x1 extra point but two
connecting bones that are just going
together and pushing the rogue that's in
front of it if we have sometimes looked
behind the pawns the points are stopped
but if the rook is in front of the pawns
and the king is there to support the
pawns I think this is just a technical
win yeah and even if white got a few
extra Tempe and does manage so let's say
get the kings of e7 and pawn to c7
there's many cases where black is just
happy sacrificing the rook for the C
pawn and then being able to win the game
with the King and two pawns against the
lone rook with white skin being too far
away I agree so we are spending some
time in the tournament B let's let's go
to the tournament a we have the last
game between Benjamin Bach and Peter
Prohaska
we predicted a quick draw they are still
playing still fighting yeah I almost
forgot about this game I was falling
asleep to it earlier look at White's
pawn structure
having two sets of isolated double pawns
I guess it was some attempt to make
progress but okay the game is continuing
and what could have been a quick draw is
is turning into a very very long fight
from the white side I mean you have to
be somewhat creative to to keep the game
going from this position yes but what is
your prediction is still a draw would
you be okay playing this with Magnus I
mean I think the the more pawns I get
traded the more the easier it is to hold
the position I mean I'm afraid of Magnus
Carlsen but in a position like this I
think it should be it should be pretty
simple black is pretty much guaranteed
to win the pawn in each - maybe we can
predict some move like King f3 rook to
h2 King g3 black is just gonna keep the
rook on each one and I mean the all of
whites pawns are actually long-term
weaknesses given they can't be defended
by each other and meanwhile I just don't
see where white is making progress in
this position so let's go back maybe to
tournament B we know what's happening it
is Tata Ebrahim ions and Andres -
copying game so maybe again see if
there's a progress in cameo dragons game
against Alejandro Ramirez yeah that
seems like the the one game where it's a
bit difficult to predict the result
kamil dragon clearly playing for the way
and I do have to mention if he wins his
game and Andre wins his game which Andre
is expected to win Camille will not
clinch a first place after today he'll
have to at least draw tomorrow so but
it's still very important for the the
standings if he can win this game gives
him a very big lead and probably he
would like to avoid any potential
playoff after round 9 tomorrow
and just by the time how much Alejandra
Ramirez is spending in this position
it's over seven minutes right now we can
see how unpleasant it is for him and how
difficult to find a position where a
line where he's happy yeah I do like the
angle the camera angle right there we
can see both players leaning forward
kind of the classic chess player pose
and I mean Alejandro his posture seems
to be very acute and in the way that
he's sitting yeah given the amount of
time he spent on this position there's
so many lines to calculate as we've seen
and it's not easy as the time is click
as the time is ticking down it's not
easy to choose maybe the most precise
line sometimes these positions you need
to take a long long thing to to fully
understand so I feel like we have a
clearer picture about what's happening
in the games so maybe let's talk about
the 2018 Grantchester it's about to
start in one month and yeah in one month
Paris and Lou even right yeah pretty
sure the fields have been determined the
events happening in st. Louis will take
place in August starting with the st.
Louis rapid and blitz running from
August 9th through the 16th last year
was the first edition of the tournament
and I was here in person it was such an
incredible event just witnessing so many
super GM's including Kasparov playing
playing some very high-level blitz and
following this tournament we have the
sixth annual Sinquefield Cup which is
the very prestigious tournament top
grandmasters are being there sometimes
Magnus Carson Fabiano caravana who is
who Santos is his home time but so far
we don't have a determined players who
are gonna play here right and we should
mention I'm just being told we have five
unique winners of the same fell Cup no
one has repeated victory in this
tournament will we have a 6-1 of what
are the odds I mean it's it's going to
be an interesting event and I think it's
going to be very exciting for the the
spectators watching around the con
tree around the world but especially the
ones in st. Louis I know every year they
have an autograph session before the
event where I mean hundreds of
spectators come out a lot of hardcore
chest fans to get autographs from the
top players and they have grandmasters
here doing site analysis very great
events if you are able to come here we
definitely recommend it otherwise make
sure to watch it on Grantchester org and
I know that we have a result in group a
group a result Peter Benjamin Bach we
thought it will be a quick draw
it was a long draw but still a draw yeah
after King age six
Oh interesting we had the position where
White had captured on each for maybe it
was a error with the GGT board the pawns
were not traded but still not much life
in this position I don't think we have
to spend much time talking about this
this final game in Group A so soon we
will look at the standings in Group a
group a but now let's go back to Group B
to the leader of the term and come out
dragon against Alejandro Ramirez do we
have any new moves there I see a fight
being played my idea is actually
happening did you say a 5 yes oh you did
say 5 yeah
wow so allowing allowing the king to
capture on B 5 and now it's probably
going to lead to the cat versus Mouse
scenario where White's king will kind of
scatter scurry across the board trying
to find shelter I mean we should note of
course rook
can't take on a 5 do to rook take a 5
then the real Connie 7 would be left
hanging so I think we can expect King
take d5 and then I mean you would be
protecting group 2 F 3 and I'm just
being told that we have another result
in Group E and race 2 copying one
against our F Abraham Ian we talked
about the rook and games it was a matter
of technique and
the game concluded they are signing the
score sheets Kings in the center
position he may have chances to to also
be playing for the first was it for the
first fall in a group B yeah we can see
Tata there does not seem too happy with
the game it's tough having such a long
game and being ground down like this
where I mean you're defending the whole
game you try and try and try it but
Andres technique just too strong for
Tata and yeah this means that Andre
still has some small chances to to fight
for first place in Group B camille
dragon trying to push for a win today
but we're not going to have a clinch
winner after today yeah so we have last
game happening camel dragon against
Alejandro Ramirez so maybe let's see the
graphics of the results of round a
around 8 in the group a not sure if we
have those graphics prepared oh we do
round a we had we had to decisive games
today euro Jared look unexpectedly
defeating the tournament leader of a sea
star Bailey so it's going to make for a
very interesting round tomorrow also had
Geoffrey Zhang defeating Alexander and
itch
let's take a look at the standings and
see who's in contention for first place
tomorrow
the sea star Bailey now tied with
version of Kobe and I'm sure both
players don't want to lose tomorrow
they're either gonna go for a win or
maybe just take a solid draw and accept
a potential playoff and then we also
have Sam Savion and yarrow jariabek with
some outside chance of getting first
place and we have to keep in mind that
Sam Simon explained was safe tomorrow so
Sam Simon may be still playing for the
first thought in the tournament
that's a really good point if Sam wins
his game tomorrow he'll leap frogged of
a sieve and he could potentially he
could potentially take clear first if he
wins and the Cobian loses or he could
have some sort of playoff so this is
what we want to see we want to see it
coming down to the very last round in
this case with four
players having a shot to take the crown
let's take a look at the results of
Group B yeah with with one game still
pending
Oh actually uh well the one game that
was pending is now over Tata of Avraham
Ian losing to andrey zhuk open and
impressive play from D Norris to do a
cassava defeating Sergei montzingo also
had a few relatively quick draws Josh
Vidal drawing JJ Oliver on D and Robert
Auguste Arion drawing V Amir Bellus so
let's take a look at the standings and
see where this puts us Camille Dragon
should still be in clear first after
this round as he is playing for a win if
he wins the game he'll be a full point
ahead only needing a draw tomorrow to
get first place if he draws a game it's
gonna be a bit more interesting but I
mean both both groups coming down to the
final day this is what we want to see so
let's look let's look at the pairings
for Group A for last round round nine in
Group A we have Jeffrey's young playing
Benjamin book green ajumma biobank
Alexandre Indyk verrico beyond playing
Daniel Friedman passive der Bailey
playing Sam seven and last board Peter
Prohaska again Sierra shareable deathly
some exciting matchups for tomorrow in
Group A let's take a look at the
pairings for group B tomorrow also some
exciting matchups
Vladimir ballast against de Norris to do
a cassava JJ ollie mirandy against
Robert August Arion Andre sook open
against Josh Reed L Alejandra Ramirez
playing his good friend taught at
Abraham Ian may be speculating a quick
draw in that game and then we also have
Sergei about saenko against the
tournament leader Camille dragon so we
have many exciting matches but no one is
yet - no one is a clear winner so please
tune out tomorrow see what's happening
we will start the game starts at 11:00
a.m. and we're gonna start the broadcast
tomorrow two hours earlier at 1:30 p.m.
Central Time
be sure to set your alarm clocks I know
we'll be setting ours as well see you
tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you